come on mal get the gang back together
for one more movie ah
no I'm in charge we don't know what
we're going to do after the end at
descendants three so tell evj Audrey and
the rest of the crew to make descendants
for happened if this is the end of an
era we are not ready if we could use one
magic spell from your spell book we
would wish for d4 to become a reality if
we meet a little magic to keep this
going it's just sometimes for happening
it's not likely that means the cast may
officially be hanging up there villain
kit outfits we're good
but fans are still holding out hope that
Disney will decide to go forward with
the fourth film it's time that we take
the barrier down forever here's
everything we know the program is shut
down you didn't think this was the end
of the story did you well for
descendants it just might be with the
recent tragic events and several new
developments there's a good possibility
that descendants or is a wish that will
never come true I'm sorry I just I
thought I was afraid to tell me that
means B 3 will be Disney Channel's final
film for the franchise here's everything
we've been able to find out about the
fate of descendants for the descendants
director is the first to confirm our
suspicions about d4 Kenny Ortega Kenny
Ortega is the genius behind descendants
1 2 & 3 as well as the High School
Musical movies it would be nearly
impossible for Disney to move on to
descendants or without Kenny and at the
helm as director so when he took to
Instagram to write a post thanking fans
all over the world for sharing in their
descendants dreams it seemed like a
farewell you wrote that the fans help
make their dreams come true the video
with this heartfelt caption showed a
behind-the-scenes video of the
descendant 3 cast rehearsing for the
movie it seemed like his final goodbyes
to the possibility of descendants for we
all know that they lost an irreplaceable
cast member so how would they move
forward after such a heartbreaking blow
additionally Kenny was discussing the
possibility of a high school musical for
in the future it would be hard for him
to focus on descendants for
if he was going to be working on a new
High School Musical for Disney this is a
pretty good indicator that d4 is not
happening new and upcoming projects for
the cast of d3 ever since production
wrapped on descendents three the
original cast has been super busy it
appears as though no one is clearing
their calendars to make room for
descendants or for instance according to
Jay 14 there is a rumor going around
that dove Cameron may star in a movie
based on the Broadway musical Wicked
she would make an amazing Glinda however
if dove takes that role she'll be too
busy to even consider doing another
descendants film it also seems that Deb
Cameron has taken a break from the small
screen to follow her passion and theater
she has recently starred in clueless on
Broadway and light in the Piazza in
London with all of that action it would
be hard for this Broadway Beauty to pull
herself away and put on that purple wig
for descendants for on the final day of
filming descendants three dub posted
something on her Instagram that suggests
it's truly the end of an era she posted
a pic of the core for villain kids hands
underneath the pic was a handwritten
note that read dear diary today is the
last day of descendants
maybe dub knew all along that this was
the end just like her co-star Sophia
Carson is not slowing down anytime soon
she is currently in production filming a
new Netflix movie about dance
it's called veal the beef does that mean
Sophia is hanging up her long blue wig
for good the idea that we may never see
Eevee again on the small screen after d3
is just too depressing
Sophia officially said goodbye to her
character Eevee on Instagram she posted
a picture of her with dub booboo and
Cameron the caption read dear world
today is a wrap on descendants three
there will never ever be enough words
she thanked the fans from the bottom of
her heart then really kicked us in the
fields when she wrote that they will
forever be our Eevee now Jay and Carlos
that seems pretty final doesn't it it
appears that booboo Stewart is also not
clearing his schedule for descendants
forward he has starred in a string of
films and TV shows since production
wrapped onto
and in three most notably he's playing
the role of Vic Lakota in the upcoming
TV series Paradise City with the series
set to air later this year bubu probably
won't have much time for another
descendants movie he hasn't mentioned
The Descendants movies very much at all
on social media maybe it's too painful
for him to say goodbye
the barrier will come down as it right
now it's not likely that we're going to
see another descendants movie after
number three but you never know the last
high school musical came out in 2008 now
11 years later Kenny Ortega is
entertaining the idea of doing a High
School Musical 4 that's a good indicator
that descendants 4 may still have a shot
we just hope they don't wait until 2030
to make it happen what do you guys think
will Disney make a descendants for
sometime in the future let us know in
the comments give this video a big
thumbs up if you want to see descendants
or happen as much as we do and subscribe
to our channel to stay up to date with
our latest videos thanks for watching
the things see you next time
[Music]